[Hank] Good morning John.
(music)
[Jenna Marbles] I, personally live for the
hugs, like I live for VidCon, I live for those
meet and greets.
[Fred Seibert] You are defining the culture
that people will talk about for decades to
come.
[Grace Helbig] It's about the value of an
audience and about the value of honesty.
[Jeffrey Katzenberg] Those who are in it today
are the ones who are going to understand it
the best tomorrow, and be a part of it as
it evolves.
That's what I'm investing in.
I want to be a part of this as it grows.
[Toby Turner] It's just nonstop happiness.
[Bethany Mota] I love Vidcon.
[John Cozart] Lots of not sleeping.
[Burnie Burns] Out of 12 million subs, 12,000
people is what got us to where we were shattering
records.
[Michelle Phan] Just having the ability and
the freedom to create whatever you want.
[Song] You took my heart in tow.
How could I let you go?
I doubt anyone can keep up, keep up, keep
up, keep up, keep up with you.
Yeah, I don't anyone can keep up, keep up,
keep up, keep up, keep up with you.
Just keep on river gone is my friend.
Just keep on river gone is mine.
Hank: VidCon 2015 is officially a thing that
is going to be a thing!
We started VidCon back in 2010 because online
video was amazing, and we wanted there to
be a time and a place where it could exist
in the real world for a weekend.
Now, headed into its sixth year, it has gotten
to be quite a big thing.
It's a convention and a conference and a celebration
and a discussion, and I'm gonna spend the
rest of this video talking about it.
Last year, VidCon had 20,000 people at it,
and this is gonna be the first year where
VidCon doesn't grow.
We're gonna cut of tickets.
Basically, the same size as last year.
But we are changing some things, so let's
talk about that.
First, we're still doing the photo signing
meet-and-greet thing at VidCon, but we're
basically Disney Fast-Passing it.
Everyone who registers for a Community Track
ticket will, in early Spring, get a message
asking them to rank the people that they would
like meet in order that they would like to
meet them.
Based on that ranking, the system will assign
tickets to people.
If you get a ticket, your badge becomes your
pass.
There's a barcode on it that will let you
into the line.
You just have to show up like a half an hour
before the signing starts, 'cause you're guaranteed
to be in the line.
The goal is that everyone will arrive at VidCon
knowing what to expect.
Second, the whole convention center.
Same number of people, twice as much space.
We're gonna have five main floor stages that
everyone at the conference will have access
to.
These stages will have things like panels
on the culture of online video and the internet,
including discussions of race and gender.
They'll host performances and interviews and
audience Q&As and live shows and dance parties
and concerts and contests.
And having all of this based on the ground
floor has allowed us to, number three, create
a new track, the Creator Track, for people
who aren't just fans but who are interested
in the process and craft and business of creating
online video.
There will be panels, workshops, and discussions,
a lounge specifically for Creator Pass holders,
and a Creator-specific keynote session.
It's slightly more expensive and, because
of limited capacity in the signing hall, it
doesn't have access to any of the signings
or photos, but it includes all of the rest
of the downstairs content.
Vidcon 2015 is going to be, I think, fantastic.
We've got a great team put together and we're
already designing a bunch of amazing content
that I'm really excited about.
I know that a mast majority of people that
want to go to Vidcon can't go to Vidcon just
because of, you know, size of the planet.
So, of course, I have to end this video by
just apologizing to all of you who can't come.
The good news is, the real culture of online
video happens right here and you have access
to that, I assume, because of how you are
listening to my words.
John, for the last time, in a while at least,
I'll see you tomorrow.
Just a final Pizzamas end screen about how
great this has been to do it this way for
a couple of weeks.
I can't keep it up, but I'm so glad we did
it.
John, I know it was even harder for you being
on the set and everything, but, thanks for
doing it.
It's been so cool.
Thanks to everyone for being here for Pizzamas.
It's fun, it's so good, it felt good.